hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime uproar and why horikoshi
why damn it
all right well the mha manga just gave
us a chapter that is both truly epic and
absolutely heartbreaking and i really
don't know how to feel about this a
major death just occurred and i'm
definitely not happy about it but at the
same time this tragic sacrifice could be
a massive game changer in the war
between the heroes and villains it won't
be easy but we need to talk about this
as always you guys know what to do if
you enjoy these videos if you want to
see more just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps with the youtube algorithm and if
you're new here or you watch our videos
but you haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet it would help me out a lot
if you took the time to subscribe hit
that bell and then select the option
that says all if you don't go through
all of those steps you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
finally this video will of course
contain boku do hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter ended
with shigaraki managing to get close
enough to america-chan to grab her face
this happened because stars and stripes
refused to sacrifice the lives of some
of her comrades in order to squash
shigaraki before he could reach her the
big question that i had at the end of
that chapter was whether shigaraki was
going to try and kill america chan right
away or whether he was going to try to
steal her quirk first i assumed that he
couldn't do both things at once and i
also assumed that america chan would
have used some sort of rule on herself
before shigaraki arrived i was convinced
that stars and stripes could still
survive this fight despite allowing
herself to be grabbed by shigaraki one
thing i didn't anticipate is that
shigaraki can apparently steal her quirk
and decay her body at the same time but
let's take it step by step we start off
from the perspective of shigaraki and it
is clear that in this moment the
all-for-one persona is absolutely
dominant it is obvious that all for one
is the one leading the internal
monologue that we're seeing a monologue
in which all for one talks about how
much he hated that new order and one for
all always seemed to be working together
to toward him we then see a panel of
deku and stars and stripes standing side
by side as if they are fighting together
as a team but i don't think that this is
literally what all for one is saying i
don't think he means that dec when stars
and stripes ever physically fought
together against him i think he means
that one for all has been his main
obstacle in japan while america and new
order have been the main thorn in his
side on the international stage all for
one reveals that he was using a network
of villains from other countries to
cause as many problems in those
countries as possible to keep the
international heroes busy and prevent
them from helping the heroes in japan
all for one was hoping to delay the
arrival of the international heroes at
least until his new body was complete
and until he had stolen one for all
after that he wouldn't have too much of
a problem dealing with the international
heroes including stars and stripes and
new order all for one's ultimate plan
was to steal both one for all and new
order and he believes that if he can do
that the war will be over he will be
able to take control not only of japan
but of the entire world but america chan
didn't take all for one's bait instead
of waiting for her government's approval
she flew out to japan immediately before
all for one's new body was complete as a
result he was forced to take a massive
gamble and this is something that i
talked about in previous videos all for
one decided to intercept stars and
stripes and take her on before his body
was complete because allowing america
chant to meet up with the japanese
heroes was way too risky if the japanese
heroes had new order on their side then
the villains would be in trouble and
stealing one for all may end up being
impossible so all for one decided to
risk fighting stars and stripes before
she could reach the shores of japan it
was dicey for a time but in this moment
it seems that all for one's gamble had
paid off he looks like he's about to
steal new order while also decaying
amerika chan's body along the way then
he will not only have new order for
himself but one of his biggest obstacles
america's strongest hero will also have
been eliminated at the same time but as
we predicted america knew about decay
ahead of time and she had placed a rule
upon herself she placed the rule that
she kathleen bate which is presumably
her full name will not decay
so it seems that the k will not work on
her but even so all for one is in the
process of stealing new order i thought
that maybe she would place a rule on
herself that makes her body something
other than solid such as a liquid or
sand or something along those lines
that would protect her from decay while
also preventing all for one from
touching her however maybe essentially
turning herself into a logia user is
beyond the capacities of new order
otherwise she probably would have done
it meanwhile the jets are still there on
the battlefield and one of the pilots is
furious that america chan chose to put
herself in danger rather than sacrifice
his life for the greater good then
suddenly all for one declares that new
order has been stolen in trying to
protect her body from decay she let her
quirk get stolen and without her quirk
she won't be able to protect her body
anyway so it's a lose-lose scenario for
america chan but this is a shown in
series and things are not going to be
that easy for the villain he immediately
tries to use new order to place a rule
on the atmosphere just like stars and
stripes had done earlier but before he
can even finish speaking off one
realizes that something is wrong
something is terribly wrong shigaraki's
body suddenly puffs up and begins to
break apart violently like there's an
actual war going on underneath his skin
all for one realizes that tomorrow
shigeraki's body is breaking apart
because all of the different quirks that
are stored inside are now suddenly
rupturing as it turns out before
shigaraki attacked her america-chan had
placed a rule upon new order itself
this rule stated that new order will
revolt against other quirks and so as
soon as all for once stole new order and
brought it inside of shigaraki's body
new orders started savagely attacking
the quirk factors of all those other
stolen quirks stars and stripes knew
that getting her quirk stolen and being
killed by all for one would be the worst
case scenario ideally she would have
liked to have protected her body as well
but because she chose not to sacrifice
her comrades she had to make a difficult
decision she had to sacrifice her
physical body in order to allow new
order to be stolen so that new order
would turn into a booby trap for all for
one being the absolute badass that she
is america-chan says that her life means
nothing compared to stopping a worldwide
threat like all for one in shigaraki and
she then says an emotional thank you to
all of her brothers for everything
they've done for her meanwhile
shigaraki's body is crumbling under the
stress of all of his quirks rebelling
against each other and cannibalizing
themselves this must be absolute hell
for both tomorrow and all for one their
shared body is being torn to pieces from
the inside and yet because they have
super regeneration the body keeps
repairing itself only to be torn apart
again that sounds absolutely terrible
when you think about it all for one
knows that the quirk all for one works
in a very specific way the rules of all
for one state that other quirks can be
either taken or given but they can never
be outright destroyed so the villain
can't just choose to discard the quirks
that are currently going crazy inside of
him he has to find a way to give them
away to someone and he plans to make
america change pilots his sacrificial
lambs for their part the pilots are
still hitting the villain with sustained
laser fire they can see that chikaraki
has been weakened from the inside by
stars and stripes and they know that in
order to accomplish this america chan
has sacrificed her own life the pilots
are now determined not to let her
sacrifice go to waste and they are
giving the villain everything they've
got and while the personification of the
new order quirk factor continues to tear
shigaraki and all for one apart from the
inside america-chan's physical body is
unfortunately getting thanos her final
thought is of all might she knows that
because he saved her that day she was
able to live a wonderful dream she was
able to lead the life of a true hero
this sacrifice is her way of paying all
my back for everything he's done for her
the chapter ends with all for one facing
off against what he calls the ghost of
all might it is the very core of stars
and stripes as character manifested
inside chicago's body through her stolen
quirk factor our girl america chan
smiles one last time and gives a final
salute before her entire body
disintegrates
no dammit horikoshi no
ah what a tragic end for america's
strongest hero an incredibly interesting
badass character with an insane quirk i
wanted to see so much more of her her
character had so much potential for
development and now she's gone man
sometimes i wish that mha was more like
black clover when it comes to deaths at
least the deaths of waifus anyway yet
another thick waifu bites the dust after
midnight and of course the female nomu
definitely not cool and not very daijobu
but with that said we know that the core
of someone's quirk factor can survive
its original owner one for all is proof
of that and before she died america
channel was able to turn her quirk
factor into a deadly weapon that is
programmed to destroy all for one and
shigaraki from the inside it was a bold
and extremely brave strategy and a truly
noble sacrifice by a genuine hero but
what happens now realistically shigaraki
all for one is the main villain of the
story so he
they are not going to be defeated
anytime soon that means that all for one
will definitely find a way out of this
trap that stars and stripes has set for
him and his way out is already
foreshadowed by the appearance of that
flying nomu in the final panels of the
chapter yes you heard that right that
freaking flying nomu is back again dude
didn't the snowmoor already get
destroyed multiple times by lasers
tiamat missiles and that self-destruct
command that shigaraki gave it like yes
i understand the hai and nomu have super
regeneration but this seems like a bit
much my guess is that all for one slash
shigaraki will use the flying nomu to
get away from the lasers and eventually
the villain will find a way to get rid
of new order unless he gets rid of a new
order or tries to get rid of every other
quirk except new order amerika chan's
quirk will continue attacking him from
the inside and with such constant
attacks all for one will not be able to
even function properly let alone take
over the world as great as new order is
all for one is not about to get rid of
all of his other quirks just to keep new
order so he is almost certainly going to
give a new order away in order to save
himself the big question is who will get
new order will it be one of the pilots
will it be one of all for one's henchmen
maybe a henchman who was born quirkless
will he just give it to the flying nomu
itself after the no move flies him to
safety if that happened then both the
nomu and new order would probably end up
perishing but at least all for one would
live to fight another day either way it
seems that stars and stripes of
sacrifice succeeded in preventing all
for one from ever effectively using new
order in the future and that is a big
thing because as you will recall all for
one thought that with new order and one
for all he would be able to take over
the entire world without problems but
even without new order he is still an
incredibly powerful villain so this
battle between good and evil is far from
over as i said earlier this chapter was
both epic in many ways and also tragic i
have a ton of respect for america chan
and her sacrifice but at the same time
it really sucks that she was killed off
right after being introduced and just as
we were starting to love her beautiful
badassery i really have mixed feelings
about all of this and the fact that
stars and stripes didn't get to see all
mine again and the fact that she never
got to meet all my successor deku are
kind of gut wrenching let me know what
you guys think about this mind-blowing
chapter are you upset about america
john's death or are you content with her
heroic sacrifice or maybe a little bit
of both what is going to happen with all
for one slash shigaraki now and what
will happen to new order will one of the
pilots end up with it will the nomu end
up with it or will all for one transfer
it to someone else will this traumatic
experience of new order tearing him up
from the inside triggers something
within shigaraki and i mean tomorrow
shigaraki aka tenko
will the internal rebellion of new order
prompt tomoda's consciousness to awaken
and start fighting against all for one
once again don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you enjoyed this video and you want us
to keep it going with the mha content
just leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to anime uproar or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopro a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma this man is an absolute mad lad
and a disciple of lord twego himself i
also can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa hinokami and water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
kaido might be a gyarados dylan isidor
spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist monkey d quilly cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired ravens steelers on hell cruise
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia fat boy games jessica
rabbit and jeremy phillips if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you